this video is sponsored by Squarespace
anime mentors come in all forms and
shapes and have become an industry
staple as far as character archetypes
and Shonen are concerned I mean our
heroes starting their journeys can't
figure out things on their own as far as
the beginning of their journeys are
concerned it's up to the mentor to guide
them and kick start their adventure
until the hero's grown strong enough
these people would probably sit at the
top of the shows power level charts at
least unlike the examples from other
forms of media these anime mentors won't
have the habit of dying on their pupils
or will they without further ado let's
get on with the list
[Music]
for the first mentor on our list we have
Lisa Lisa joke's on anyone who thought
that a list of mentors would be filled
with old veterans or goofy bystander
guys how about a hottie to start off the
list a mentors can be alluring as they
come and Lisa Lisa's an example of that
Lisa Lisa is one of the key mentors in
the series being seizes Harmon master
she's powerful to easily demolishing
vampire's pillar men and zombies she's
also a really tough mentor to joseph
joestar and a master of putting up and
uncaring facade in front of him despite
appearing in her 20s she's actually 50
years old I guess it's just a thing with
Harmon uses and their slow aging number
Knight is no stranger to 90s kids it's
good old gang Kai snarky sarcastic gang
Kai finds herself on this list as the
former champion of the dark tournament
in Hue hakusho that's definitely not an
easy feat she's a badass who subjects
the poor you skate to trading from Hell
being domineering harsh and
condescending towards her student the
true definition of a sink or swim mentor
she really wants her pupil to go beyond
his limits making her Japanese name
really fitting in a sense then again
it's not easy to train a student to
inherit her incredible powers
[Music]
let me ask you a question who do you
think is itchy goes most important
mental rukia now personally I'd give the
title to our friendly neighborhood store
keeper but Rukia was the one who gave
Ichigo his powers yes but isn't it
O'Hara that unlocked ichigo's full
powers after he got owned by byakuya
more than that aura Hara is also
responsible for preparing the rest of
the gang for the trip to awake on Mundo
it soon revealed that aura Hara is
indeed a lot stronger than he seems more
than being a very capable Shinigami
he was once also a captain of the gotei
13 his intelligence and preparation
knows no bounds and he's instrumental in
ending the conflicts of several arcs now
go read the manga to see more of him in
action and stay for his awesome bankai
it was only a matter of time before we
get a badass mentor in the form of a
little girl that's anime fire and yes
there's little girls one of the
strongest characters of the series
according to Takashi's power level
charts Biscay is first encountered by
GaN and Kilowog during the green island
arc and is the one responsible for
training them in refining their nen you
know the funny thing with Biscay is that
she's a mentor who conceals her true
form using her powers something you
probably wouldn't want to see don't
worry she feels the same way the desire
to get rid of her original appearance is
the one thing responsible for granting
her powers you'd rather be trained by a
little girl than a buff Amazon right
no you wouldn't expect to have a top
mentor list without Jiraiya would you
besides the hots yes for women the
outgoing Jiraiya is mostly known as the
mentor for our titular protagonist in
Naruto and what better mentor than one
of the strongest shinobi of the leaf
village
don't let that silly deviant attitude
for you the only did Uriah become a
teacher for Naruto he also trained
Minato and the army orphans ultimately
beneath that super perverted nature like
someone who truly sees the potential in
his latest pupil the prophesized chosen
one it helps that unlike Nagato his
newest student that is Naruto if you
still haven't guessed him fully accepts
and integrates his optimistic and
hopeful outlook in life his last stand
provided some of the most dramatic
moments in the Shippuden anime
[Music]
with the halfway mark now and it's time
to roll out korosensei what's that
tentacle monster doing here you probably
haven't watched assassination classroom
have you don't let that silly and
harmless appearance fool you this is one
badass teacher credited with destroying
the moon at the start of the series
korosensei is by all means of being of
mass destruction blessed with a plethora
of powers assassinating him is pretty
much impossible however that doesn't
mean that he's that huge stereotypical
doomsday type creature but all the talk
about him being a monster korosensei
gets along really well with his students
and serves as an excellent teacher
eventually it's revealed that past that
invincible and overpowered facade lies a
troubled soul that desires weakness
despite the intimidating nature that
lies underneath the huge smile
korosensei
isn't so bad after all just make sure to
follow this one cardinal rule don't ever
try to harm his students make way for
the next female to grace the list is Umi
Curtis at number 4 that's a name I
haven't heard in the world Azumi Curtis
his favorite way of introducing herself
is by calling herself a mere housewife
really who falls for that I mean just
look at her don't let her introduction
for you she's best known for being the
mentor to the Elric brothers teaching
them alchemy and martial arts it takes
one huge badass to survive for Briggs
for a month with nothing but a machete
but it also takes a whole level of
badass to scare the lights out of the
Elric's even when they're in the face of
the actual foes looks like the training
from hell did a number assume he may be
scary as hell
but that doesn't mean that she doesn't
have hidden depths I'd say that she
leans more on the tough love spectrum of
things in fact she's notably good at
empathizing with the Elric's after
learning about their attempt at human
transmutation
[Music]
[Music]
next on the list is Silver's Raley
one-pieces Silver's Raley is a living
legend he's one of the remaining crew of
the Roger pirates led by the legendary
Goldie Roger himself thanks to him Luffy
mastered the use of hockey
he has since quit piracy but that
doesn't mean that he's grown rusty over
the years just ask he's a rube
going toe-to-toe with an admiral is no
easy feat and Rayleigh more than lives
up to his nickname of the dark King
cookie to those who can guess what makes
his feet all the more astounding he
doesn't have a devil fruit of course he
doesn't want to hype someone to be
really strong beyond imagination
give him all those feats and make sure
that he doesn't have a devil fruit now
that's how you build a badass
[Music]
the world's greatest hero all might is
next on the list
who doesn't know the greatest paragon of
justice these days I'm not exaggerating
when I say that about all my who else
can inspire a whole generation to become
heroes none other than everyone's
favorite all-american themed hero you
can't get a better teacher than him if
you're a student at UA and you couldn't
ask for a better mentor than the world's
greatest hero Beck who is surely one
lucky hero being not only the recipient
of powers from the world's greatest hero
but also his hand-picked successor when
faced with a whole league of villains as
powerful as the ones in my hero academia
you'd be glad to have all my by your
side no other hero brings terror to
villains while being a caring mentor as
well as he does
whoever said that hero mentors have to
be shining Paragons of Justice who love
their pupils with all their hearts
you're delusional
Pia cosa duro finds himself topping this
list praised attitude and power rarely
do we see someone who's so condescending
of his own student and confident in his
own abilities have the capacity to back
it up but this guy does he doesn't care
whether he faces a master swordsman or a
hulking giant he'll tear through them
like the badass that he is yes
ken shins own mentor is Bar None the
strongest character in the series none
can even come close to matching him in
swordsmanship even shishio's nothing but
a puny roadblock if he's to be believed
unfortunately he just doesn't care he
coasted Errol cares little about the
world and its conflicts he's that big of
a badass to be far beyond those puny
conflicts and that's why he finds his
way to the top of the list
[Music]
and that's gonna do it for this one the
top ten badass mentors in Shonen anime
before I end this video I'd like to give
a shout out to this video sponsors
Squarespace Squarespace is one of the
easiest to use and beautiful website
development tools out there with 24/7
365 day support you can find everything
in one platform there's no need to add
additional plugins no updates and no
patches ever it's flexible for any kind
of website for musicians designers
artists or if you just want to open an
anime blogging website you can do it all
right here you don't even need to have
any website coding experience either
Squarespace is offering my viewers 10%
off their first purchase just go to
Squarespace calm / Vinnie tube that's VI
n I I t ub e or just click the link in
the description to sign up and start
building your online presence today got
anyone you want to add to the list got
any suggestions for future lists I'd
love to hear from you if you're up for
more similar content don't forget to hit
the like and subscribe button I'll see
you next time on video
[Music]